Let's create a nice atmosphere for watching the fireworks. Let's
calm down. I
can smell Meccha-chan from the inside.
Wait, this is the smell
of Hashino and Mirika, and the smell of a woman I don't know.
How can I tell that it's beauty?  I guess you remember the girl's scent.
So,
while you were separated from me, you were with many different women.
There's nothing wrong with that.
[Music] It's
just that we were in close contact due to circumstances, so it's amazing.
Nothing really happened, Hanabi.  I ca
n't lie, Taemama Anaya. It's my
first summer fireworks show since I've been with Nao. I have to
enjoy it. I've
spent many summers with Naoya since we were kids,
but now...  Unlike back then, we're lovers
[music]
And
now we're
adults  Fireworks,
don't tell me to watch it. Today's fireworks display
has ended.
[Music]
Eh